amis téléspectateurs bonjour vous
regardez et maintenant l'émission qui
revient avec plaisir et toujours avec
vous sur l'actualité politique de la
semaine vous connaissez le principe
hashtag et maintenant si vous souhaitez
réagir aujourd'hui sur ce plateau on
accueille des Francs Tireurs ils ont
l'art et la manière vous ne retrouverez
leurs analyses nulle part ailleurs ils
sont très intelligents ils n'ont pas
peur du débat Emmanuel Boguet Voge
bonjour Steve
une éloge pareil vous êtes communicant
président de narrative à côté de vous
Valérie Lecat bonjour vous êtes
communicante présidente de HK stratégie
Christophe hagiton est aussi avec nous
aujourd'hui bonjour sociologue militant
altermondialiste je renvoie à votre
dernier livre pour la justice climatique
stratégie en mouvement c'est publié aux
éditions les liens qui libèrent et je
lui dis couturier est avec nous
également bonjour c'est une première
pour vous vous êtes avocate vous êtes la
batonnière du barreau de Paris dans
cette émission on posera la question qui
fâche cette semaine faut-il interdire
les trottinettes en libre-service à
Paris on se demandera si un ancien
président américain se retrouvera
bientôt derrière les barreaux si avoir
des dettes c'est si grave que ça quand
on est un grand pays comme la France et
puis et puis on se demandera si Emmanuel
Macron est un bon président mais d'abord
merci président Larcher cette question
le dialogue est-il devenu impossible
pour résoudre nos désaccords on assiste
en tout cas ces derniers jours un regain
de violence dans les manifestations le
week-end dernier rassemblement interdit
aggravement dégénéré c'était dans les
Deux Sèvres mardi la mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites à elle aussi
connu son lot de débordement à gauche
certains accusent le gouvernement de
chercher l'incident écoutez
pour moi il y a une absence de réaction
des forces de l'Orne et une sorte de
complicité qui permet de pourrir
aujourd'hui le mouvement je demande à
tout le monde de bien comprendre qu'un
ministre de l'Intérieur qui est capable
d'organiser un traquenard comme celui
qui a été mis en place afin de Soline
est absolument capable de toutes les
provocations
manuel pourquoi à gauche on dit ça le
gouvernement a-t-il intérêt à avoir des
débordements dans les manifestations il
y a une instrumentalisation de tout ça
de part et gauche de à gauche comme à
droite de part et d'autre pardon une
chose est certaine c'est que le chaos
profite toujours au pouvoir dans ce
genre de dans ce genre de manifestation
dans ce genre de débordements pourquoi
parce que on veut de l'ordre et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle les
organisations syndicales avec succès ce
sont assurés que tout ce qui était sous
leur contrôle les 8 manifestations de
suite se passent se passe formidablement
bien maintenant le pouvoir à la vocation
instrumentalisée politiquement
l'opposition aussi mais finalement c'est
pas des manifestants auxquels on a eu à
faire la semaine dernière à Sainte
Soline on a eu affaire à des voyous qui
voulaient en découdre avec les forces de
l'ordre ça n'a rien à voir donc on
mélange tout et ceux qui sont le plus
mal comportés finalement dans cette
histoire là il y a les voyous bien
entendu mais il y a aussi le groupe et
les à l'Assemblée nationale et qui
instrumentalise
sur ce plateau on va faire un duel parce
que c'est très tranché la question est
très tranchée deux invités ne sont pas
d'accord à la quant à répondre à la
question suivante je vais vous poser la
question Valérie est-ce qu'il y a une
responsabilité du gouvernement s'il y a
des violences dans les manifestations
d'un côté Valérie va nous dire que non
et de l'autre Christophe va nous dire
que oui vous commencez Valérie vous avez
45 secondes bah écoutez comme ça vient
très bien d'être dit les manifestations
se sont déroulées globalement dans le
calme et un esprit très constructif sous
le contrôle des syndicats
malheureusement il y a eu ensuite et
assez récemment des Black Blocs qui se
sont joints à toutes ces violences
puissante Soline avec les grandes
bassines dont on reparlera tout à
l'heure bien évidemment la violence
provoquée par ces éléments totalement
incontrôlés a été réprimé par la police
parce que c'est son travail si vous
regardez les images et si vous montrer
tout ce qui se prenne sur la figure le
comment ne voulez-vous pas qu'il
réagisse et donc la preuve c'est qu'il y
a eu le calme avec le contrôle et les
syndicats le désordre et la violence
avec les black-box et les extrémistes
sur les machines et le gouvernement et
le ministre de l'Intérieur a fait son
travail et les gendarmes et les
policiers ont fait leur travail Vous
AVEZ LA PAROLE Christophe 45 secondes
vous n'êtes pas d'accord pour moi le
problème c'est que la France est tout à
fait à part en Europe on est le pays où
il y a le plus de violence venant de la
police pas à cause de la police
elle-même et des membres de la police
mais à cause des ordres du gouvernement
et cela sur trois niveaux premiers
niveaux il y a une doctrine des forces
de l'ordre qui est tout à fait
spécifique chez nous le pire étant ce
que le préfet d'allemand avait dit c'est
foutait rentrer dans le tas et en gros
casser les même quand c'était les
rassemblements pacifiques au moment des
gilets jaunes deuxièmement on a un
armement qui est tout à fait spécifique
et qui est interdit dans la plupart des
pays d'Europe ce sont des armes de
guerre des grenades de désencerclements
des fusils qui tirent des balles de
caoutchouc qui ont éborgné des dizaines
personne pendant le mouvement des gilets
jaunes et on est à peu près les seuls en
Europe à les utiliser et de cela de
façon massive et puis il y a un
troisième problème c'est qu'on utilise
des forces de l'ordre qui ne sont pas
formées pour faire du travail de force
de l'ordre le pire ayant été
l'enregistrement sonore de la brave qui
montre que ces méthodes de voyou peuvent
être utilisées par certains policiers
appelle au juge de paix Julie vous allez
nous trancher tout ça est-ce que déjà il
y a une spécificité du maintien de
l'ordre en France par rapport à tous nos
voisins européens alors je suis pas
forcément suffisamment renseigné pour ce
que sur ce que font nos voisins pour
pouvoir vous répondre de façon
documentée
moi ce qui m'a interpellé et ce qui a
interpellé apparemment un certain nombre
d'organismes puisque on a eu des
réactions aussi bien de la Défenseur des
droits que du Conseil de l'Europe que de
la Commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme et il se trouve du
barreau de Paris c'est peut-être le
décalage entre le nombre
d'interpellations auxquelles on a
assisté et le nombre de poursuites c'est
sur un communiqué notamment justement de
la CNCDH qui relève que le 16 mars il y
a eu 292 interpellations c'était le soir
de la place de la Concorde pour
seulement 9 poursuites ce qui veut dire
ce qui s'appelle trop ce qui veut dire
que on interpelle peut-être alors même
qu'il n'y a pas d'infraction constatée
et que ça ne nécessite dans ces
conditions pas forcément de suite et
c'est vrai que nous ce à quoi on est
extrêmement vigilant c'est à la liberté
de manifester qui est une liberté
fondamentale donc ça c'est peut-être un
point d'interrogation et pour nous un
point de vigilance pour le respect des
droits et des libertés fondamentales
dont celle de manifeste ce qui veut dire
que Gérald Darmanin a un peu la main
lourde c'est ce que vous nous dites
Valérie il y a une autre interprétation
possible des chiffres que vous donnez et
j'insiste sur le fait que la violence
dont je parle c'est plutôt la violence
des bassines que la violence des
manifestations parce que là on est
arrivé à un degré complètement supérieur
et qui est nécessité vraiment une
défense de la part des gendarmes qui a
été sur place c'est pas exactement le
même sujet avec les manifestations mais
moi je pense que le décalage entre le
nombre d'interpellations et le nombre de
poursuites peut aussi venir d'un certain
laxisme de la justice
qui ne prend pas suffisamment en compte
les interpellations qui relâchent les
gens trop facilement on avait sainte
Soline là on a eu on avait quand même
200 personnes qui étaient fichées il y a
200 personnes qui étaient dans ces
manifestations dans les Deux Sèvres qui
étaient fichés comment se fait-il dans
ce pays qu'on est dans la nature comme
ça qui est qui vont à toutes les
manifestations de ce type mettre une
violence vous avez raison que que les
forces de l'ordre des moyens
d'intervenir assez puissants mais on a
une violence très puissante dans ce pays
quand même et on peut pas non plus
laisser des jardins
on le rappelle c'est quand même des gens
qui sont sous surveillance et dont on
remarque que ils vont à répétition dans
ce type de manifestations à répétition
mettre la violence mettre le feu partout
avec des armes qui ont sur eux ils
arrivent ils sont armés quand même
fortement armés et peut-être que les 200
ne font pas l'objet de condamnation vous
avez raison mais peut-être qu'il faut
qu'il y ait un peu plus de condamnations
et que on éviterait aussi un peu de plus
de violence dans ce pays Emmanuel la
question pour moi elle est mal posée
pardon c'est pas la violence je t'en
prie je vous en parle c'est pas la
violence dans les manifestations c'est
parce que à Sainte Soline il s'agit pas
d'une manifestation on a on a franchi un
cap supérieur on a des gens qui se sont
armés de H de boule de pétanque et et
les témoignages des policiers sur place
c'est pour gens qui étaient sur place
avec les boucliers c'est pour la
première fois on nous a pas demandé de
maintenir l'ordre pour la première fois
on a eu le sentiment d'avoir affaire à
des gens qui voulaient nous tuer c'est
totalement différent et donc je pense
qu'il faut séparer les manifestations de
ces violences il y a pas eu de violence
pour moi dans les manifestations des
retraites elles se sont très bien
déroulées
à la dissociation il y a les Black Blocs
qui rentrent en jeu mais c'est pas des
manifestants je crois qu'il faut
vraiment faire la différence entre les
manifestants et les blackbirds d'un côté
ou ces espèces de dingues qui se
présentent comme des comme des
activistes écologiques à Sainte solide
et qui sont simplement que des voyous
qu'il faut mettre en prison de son côté
le gouvernement je vous donne la parole
dans un instant à Christophe que de son
côté le gouvernement rejette la
responsabilité des débordements sur la
gauche écoutez
que s'est-il passé à gauche quand on a
pas un mot quand on attaque des
commissariats des tribunaux des
préfectures des permanences de
parlementaires que s'est-il passé à
gauche pour qu'on aisse des policiers
que s'est-il passé à gauche pour faire
alliance avec Monsieur Mélenchon qui les
insultent qui les vomit et qui
finalement fait honte à tous les
électeurs de gauche
Christophe que s'est-il passé à gauche
non je vais pas répondre d'abord à cette
question c'est sur l'idée de nos voisins
européens et qu'est-ce qui se passe
ailleurs la violence auquel on assiste
ça ne se souligne comme ailleurs et que
je déplore comme tout le monde c'est pas
ça le sujet elle n'est pas spécifique à
la France y compris le ministre de
l'Intérieur a parlé d'éléments venant
d'italier d'Allemagne parce que dans ces
deux pays il y a eu des manifestations
très violentes je rappellerai simplement
celle de juillet 2017 pendant le G20 ou
la ville d'Hambourg a été je dis pas
rasé ce serait trop mais bien saccagé
bon il y a en effet là-bas comme ici des
moments où il y a des violences qui
peuvent être tout à fait il y a pas de
la spécificité la réponse des Allemands
et d'autres pays européens je pense au
néerlandais à de nombreuses autres en
particulier au nord et dans la partie
elle est manique de l'Europe c'est ce
qu'ils appellent la désescalade c'est
comment trouver les moyens de faire
baisser ce niveau de tension et je pense
que c'est la bonne question à se poser
c'est pas celle que pose
je voudrais finir là dessus c'est pas
celle que pose le ministre de
l'Intérieur
tuer les flics mais je vous assure que
c'était de degré de violence tout à fait
comparable j'étais pas la manifestations
de gêne en Italie autre pays aussi
concernés et je vous assure que ce qui
s'est passé y compris à Sainte colline
n'est pas solide pardon et tout à fait
faible par rapport à ce qu'on a vu à
gêne avec des morts à l'époque bon
j'espère que ce sera pas le cas pour le
saint Soline mais pour revenir là-dessus
dans tous ces pays-là on essaie de faire
une désescalade écouter notre ministre
de l'Intérieur il ne parle pas de ça et
je dois vous pouvez pas dire que que la
police ou les gendarmes en France ne
cherche pas la désescalade on les a
toutes les manifestations se sont
passées sans aucun problème ils
attendent d'être acculé pour réagir je
veux dire vous ne ils ont ils ont des
ordres d'engagement qui sont de laisser
les gens manifester sincèrement ils ont
ils empêchent pas il y a une vraie
liberté de manifester dans ce pays je
veux dire et ils attendent vraiment le
tout dernier moment je veux dire dans
une ville comme Paris où il y a des
poubelles partout que il y a des Black
Blocs qui viennent mettre le feu faire
des énormes feux dans les poubelles que
il y a des immeubles qui ont failli être
incendiés qu'il y a des voitures pleines
d'essence et des scooters à côté on
arrive dans des situations extrêmement
dangereuses ils attendent le dernier
moment pour répliquer parce que leur
devoir c'est de protéger les tickets pas
un changement de degré dans la violence
de ces affrontements
ils doivent en effet s'adapter et moi je
voudrais juste revenir sur un point je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec vous
quand vous dites que la justice laxiste
je pense pas du tout qu'elle le soit je
pense qu'en revanche il appartient et
aux forces de police et au magistrats
qui soient du parquet ou du siège d'agir
de manière proportionnelle et je pense
que ce sont des pouvoirs qui
s'équilibrent en réalité les uns les
autres mais tous les chiffres le disent
la justice c'est vrai que c'est un
reproche qui est souvent fait à la
justice sur ces sujets là comme sur
d'autres il y a pas de laxisme il y a en
revanche une qualification juridique une
infraction a-t-elle été commise ou pas
est-ce que ça justifie des poursuites ou
pas et là-dessus on peut tout à fait
faire confiance alors en l'occurrence je
connais peut-être mieux la situation
parisienne que ce qui s'est passé
ailleurs mais effectivement une
confiance totale au parquet de Paris qui
fait tout cela avec beaucoup beaucoup de
rigueur moi j'ai quand même le sentiment
j'ai quand même le sentiment excusez-moi
que parmi très jeune parmi les violents
de ces jeunes on parle pas du tout des
manifestants je suis 100% d'accord bien
sûr on est tous d'accord parmi ces
jeunes violents vous pouvez pas
m'enlever de l'idée qu'il y a une espèce
de sentiment d'impunité qui se disent de
toute façon on va aller casser du flic
ou casser de je ne sais quoi et il va
rien nous arriver et que au bout de
l'histoire ça n'aide pas la situation
5 secondes un chiffre simplement et sans
accuser les policiers individuels mais
les consignes qui lancent sont données
on a eu par exemple en 1918 en 2018
pardon
1900019000 balles en caoutchouc qui ont
été lancés par les LBD 19000 avec un
nombre de gens qui sont retrouvés et
borniers qui est pas acceptable dans un
pays comme la France donc il y a des
niveaux qui ont été franchis c'est la
des escalopes
est-il un bon président cette semaine le
chef de l'État fait en tout cas un grand
plongeon dans les sondages sur fond
évidemment de réforme des retraites 70%
des Français estiment qu'il est un
mauvais président selon le dernier
baromètre odoxal pour Public Sénat
Emmanuel c'est quoi déjà un bon
Président
c'est quelqu'un qui sent l'opinion c'est
quelqu'un qui sent le pays et Emmanuel
Macron a perdu totalement
cette capacité là alors je sais qu'il
faut pas faire des tunnels dans une
émission de télé mais je voudrais juste
qu'on prenne un petit peu des hauteurs
parce que la séquence qu'on vit elle
prend elle pour moi elle puisse sa
source dans la campagne présidentielle
avec un débat qui est enjambé par le
Président de la République alors pour
cause fond de guerre en Ukraine le soir
on voit bien que son discours à la Tour
Eiffel manque de souffle manque
d'inspiration il dit je serai le
président de tous les Français et puis
ils sont presque de gouverner contre 70%
des Français ensuite persuadé sur son
avantin que c'est pas la peine de faire
campagne simplement pour législatives la
majorité absolue va lui tomber dans les
mains il se retrouve sans majorité
absolue je vous rappelle quand même
qu'on a même eu droit à la prolongation
de Jean Castex pendant plus d'un mois
après son élection et le premier texte
alors qu'il a une majorité relative
qu'il nous sort c'est un texte qui va à
l'encontre de 70 % de la population
c'est le président Emmanuel on a compris
et c'est un très bon Président en
revanche sur la internationale pour pour
essayer de balancer de balancer le
propos Julie à vous je vous posez la
question comment on l'a posé dans le
sondage direz-vous qu'Emmanuel Macron
est un bon président alors c'est
évidemment plus compliqué que ça
elle est évident s'il a besoin d'un
avocat je serai peut-être celle-là
pas que je sois absolument convaincu en
effet par tout ce qui est fait et je
rejoins Emmanuel sur la question
peut-être de l'écoute et du fait de
sentir en effet les choses et de sentir
peut-être les raisons pour lesquelles il
a été élu je pense qu'il n'a pas été élu
que par adhésion à ce qu'il proposait je
pense qu'il a aussi été
en réaction et en rejet à Marine Le Pen
et qu'il faut sentir je pense plus cette
fragilité là et peut-être du coup tenir
un peu plus compte mais on en reparlera
peut-être tout à l'heure sur un autre
sujet de cette démocratie sociale qui
est peut-être plus participatif qui doit
coexister avec la démocratie
représentative dont autrement je suis
une fervente défenseur mais voilà mais
et puis je pense que quand vous êtes au
responsabilité quoi qu'il arrive vous
prenez des coups est-ce qu'on connaît
tellement de président de la République
en France qui ont été populaires au
moment où ils étaient aux affaires
donc c'est de toute façon à tous les
coups vous prenez quoi qu'il arrive on a
peut-être simplement un mot là aussi de
ma fenêtre
puisque les sujets justices évidemment
m'intéressent on a rarement eu un
président qui alors un peu par la force
des choses et forcer et un peu poussé
dans le dos mais qui s'est intéressé
autant à la justice avec une
augmentation absolument remarquable du
budget de la justice qui est un service
public essentiel on le rappelle jamais
assez Christophe c'est un bon Président
je pense les présidents précédents ont
aussi été un peu plus l'air mais en
et je pense que c'est parce que Emmanuel
Macron combine deux problèmes ou plus
exactement à deux problèmes le premier
il est classique c'était aussi celui de
ses prédécesseurs c'est des politiques
néolibérales qui sont rejetées par le
pays en particulier toute cette théorie
du ruissellement dans diminuer les
impôts pour les riches l'ISF la taxe la
flat taxe pour les les produits
financiers et charger ceux qui sont en
bas de l'échelle parce que évidemment la
réforme des retraites ça touche pas les
cadres ça touche évidemment les classes
populaires les employés et les retraités
mais ça se rajoute et je suis d'accord
avec vous deux le fait qu'il y a un
pouvoir présidentiel très personnel un
mépris des corps intermédiaires qui en
rajoute dans la difficulté prenez la
dernière intervention du président de la
République il y a la semaine dernière
sur la question de la réforme des
retraites
ou quasi insulter Laurent Berger en
disant qu'il était minoritaire même dans
son propre syndicat c'est pas possible
comment vous voulez essayer de négocier
avec des corps intermédiaires y compris
le plus modéré d'entre eux en le
traitant par le mépris et en disant vous
n'êtes même pas capable de gagner votre
congrès il y a quand même un problème
de façon particulièrement forte en ce
moment le 49.3 ayant accentué cette
déséquilibre de reprendre la main de
désamorcer la crise jeudi il était en
déplacement dans les Hautes-Alpes il en
a profité pour faire le point sur la
situation politique écouter le
il y a une contestation sociale qui
existe sur une réforme mais ça veut pas
dire que tout doit s'arrêter et c'est
normal on continue à travailler parce
que il se trouve que il y a toujours des
problèmes d'inflation on doit continuer
à réduire le chômage dans notre pays on
doit répondre aux problèmes de
sécheresse on doit préparer la saison à
venir on doit faire face au sujet
alimentaire on a la géopolitique qui
continue donc c'est normal je fais mon
travail Valérie se déplacement c'est
quoi c'est l'histoire de montrer qu'il y
a toujours un pilote dans l'avion sur
son crise politique et crise sociale
de reprendre la main parce que la
séquence comme on dit retraite c'est
atrocement mal passé mais
de concernant Emmanuel Macron moi je
pense que le casse du siècle qu'il a
fait en devenant président de la
République alors qu'il avait fait
extrêmement peu de politique avant il
est en train de le payer au prix fort
aujourd'hui pour deux raisons en fait un
il connaît pas la France c'est à dire
qu'il n'a pas un parcours politique
traditionnel il a pas fait 20 ans de
politique à se déplacer à avoir un
mandat local à écouter les gens à
s'approprier ce pays on parlait Jacques
Chirac je rajouterai François Hollande
c'est deux présidents qui avaient
vraiment qui l'amour de la France et qui
connaissent qui connaissait bien la
France donc c'est quand même au bout de
l'histoire un techno qui a fait
irruption en politique parce qu'il était
brillant intelligent original
de rafraîchir la politique il a échoué
c'est ce que vous êtes en train de dire
ce succès totalement inopiné il le paye
au préfet aujourd'hui parce qu'il a un
sentiment de surpuissance et de
domination il pense que de toute façon
il est intelligent et que les autres ne
comprennent rien en fait les Français ne
comprennent rien les corps
intermédiaires ne comprennent rien et
lui lui tout seul il va tout arranger
parce que il est surpuissant et plus que
les autres donc là je trouve qu'il a une
mine un peu moins réjouis qu'avant en
fait le pauvre sincèrement vous prenez
les photos au début à la fin et il
essaie de reprendre la question
aujourd'hui comment sortir de la crise
je vais vous montrer sondage 71% des
français espèrent un référendum pour
annuler le report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite comment on sort de
cette crise je suis pas connu pour être
un grand grand supporter de de la nupes
ni de ni de Jean-Christophe Rufin mais
je crois que c'est lui qui a raison il
faut qu'il y ait du Chirac un peu de
chiracle
Christophe François ruffez moi il faut
qu'il faut qu'il y ait du Chirac dans
Macron et un peu moins de Sarkozy Macron
qui plie les goal c'est tout simple
Chirac Chirac a pas promulgué le CPE et
puis voilà ça s'est arrêté là cette
retraite c'est très forme des retraites
elle est mal née depuis le départ depuis
le départ sur votre plateau j'ai dit
qu'elle se ferait jamais je maintiens
mais non mais vous verrez qu'elle
rentrera pas en application parce que
c'est pas possible on ne peut pas
gouverner contre eux 100% du corps
social 70 % des Français ça n'est pas
possible dans une démocratie comme la
nôtre et ça n'est pas un petit aéropage
de techno aussi brillant
intellectuellement soit-il enfermé
claque muret à l'Elysée pour pour lui
dire matin midi et soir qu'il a raison
il dit tout ne doit pas s'arrêter mais
tout s'arrête par sa faute tout s'arrête
et il a eu des armes constitutionnelles
dit tout à l'heure la moitié de son
électorat venait pour l'essentiel de la
gauche c'était des gens qui évidemment
n'étaient pas pour la réforme des
retraites il ne voulait pas de voir
Marine Le Pen au pouvoir et c'est pour
ça qu'ils ont voté Macron moins inclus
je peux le dire sans problème ici pour
cette raison là exactement
et s'il ne le s'il ne change pas et s'il
ne revient pas sur cette réforme le prix
politique pour lui il va être énorme je
vais vous donner un seul petit indice il
y a eu dimanche dernier le dimanche
dernier oui une élection
partielle en arrière la candidate dans
marche qui avait fait à l'époque 20 % et
qui avait été au second tour a fait ce
coup-ci 10%, ils ont perdu la moitié de
leur voix
de la gauche dissidente de nupes et qui
a refusé d'intégrer une UPS est en train
de gagner et ça c'est très très
important parce que l'autre échec de
cette histoire c'est l'échec de la
nupesse c'est surtout les siècles c'est
l'échec de la livraisse et le fait que
la gauche traditionnelle soit revenue en
tête c'est extrêmement simple
la gauche traditionnelle mais les
premiers importants et les premiers à
avoir perdu c'est en marche ils ont vu
leur voix passer alors que alors que
taurine qui est la candidate de la nups
a gardé ses voix elle a eu en gros le
même niveau de voix
vivons-nous dans un pays en faillite et
si oui est si grave que ça cette semaine
l'Insee a dévoilé le montant de la dette
française elle est très précisément de
2950 milliards d'euros sous la barre
symbolique des 3000 milliards Bruno Le
Maire se félicite le pire n'est pas
encore arrivé écoutez-le
nous sommes rentrés dans une nouvelle
ère financière où les taux d'intérêts
sont plus élevés l'ère de l'argent
gratuit c'est fini l'air ou l'étape
français pouvait emprunter à 0% c'est
fini nous empruntons aujourd'hui après
de 3% la charge de la dette c'était 30
milliards d'euros en 2021 s'est passé à
40 milliards d'euros en 2022 c'est 10
milliards d'euros uniquement sur la
charge de la dette qui pourrait être
utilement consacré aux hôpitaux au
crèche aux universités moi je ne veux
pas que nous jetons l'argent des
Français par la fenêtre en ayant une
charge de la dette qui explose ça
suppose de réduire la dette
Christophe il faut se réjouir comme
Bruno Le Maire ce qui est vrai c'est
qu'on change de cycle sur le plan
économique et l'idée de l'argent roi
qu'on pourrait distribuer à travers ce
qui est en gros ce qu'on fait depuis au
moins le covid voire auparavant ça c'est
terminé et qu'en effet on a une
inflation qui va malheureusement rester
on peut espérer qu'elle ne soit pas au
niveau de ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
mais il est difficilement pensable qu'on
aura une inflation qui reviendra à un ou
deux pour cent comme c'était le cas dans
les décennies précédentes donc le
problème de la dette est un vrai
problème ça veut pas de ça nous concerne
très concrètement de notre quotidien le
problème de l'inflation un des paradoxes
de l'inflation c'est que ça réduit la
dette puisqu'en fait sur le même stock
d'argent on a une valeur de cette dette
qui diminue tout simplement parce que la
valeur de la monnaie diminue c'est ça
l'inflation bon donc d'une certaine
façon la dette va être rognée par
l'inflation bon ce qui n'est pas
forcément une mauvaise nouvelle mais si
on veut vraiment la réduire la dette le
pire serait de réduire les dépenses
publiques c'est une question
magique on a besoin aujourd'hui d'argent
public pour la santé regardez l'état des
hôpitaux l'école en particulier le
supérieur qui est très mal de thé
aujourd'hui et le changement climatique
et pour ça il faisait tout pour ça il
faut réduire la dette mais je pense
qu'on ne coupera pas il faut savoir sur
qui ça va tomber à une augmentation
d'impôt pour les plus riches d'entre
nous
la stratégie de Bruno Le Maire c'est
justement de ne pas augmenter les impôts
pour ne pas entraîner pour ne pas
stopper la croissance et son pari c'est
de dire que la croissance va rapporter
plus de recettes fiscales ce qui a été
le cas en 2022 que prévu et que c'est
comme ça qu'on va réduire
progressivement la date la dette elle a
augmenté très violemment à deux reprises
en 2008 pendant la crise financière sous
Nicolas Sarkozy et avec le quoi qu'il en
coûte de Bruno Le Maire donc il est
sympa avec son augmentation des taux on
savait tous qu'elle allait arriver et on
savait tout ce qu'il allait falloir
payer derrière mais ce qui est
intéressant dans leur façon de faire
avec moi j'approuve assez c'est qu'au
lieu de casser la machine comme par
exemple François Hollande a fait quand
il est arrivé en augmentation en
augmentant drastiquement les impôts il
mise sur la croissance et sur le fait
c'est vrai que le développement rapport
beaucoup plus en supplémentaire que on
arrive à économiser en cassant je veux
pas avoir une discussion vraiment très
budgétaire très concrètement pourquoi
c'est inquiétant qu'on que la dette soit
frôle les 3000 milliards aujourd'hui
3000 milliards de dettes à nos enfants
et que vous c'est un chiffre absolument
considérable et qui a explosé depuis 20
ans Emmanuel ce que ça vous inquiète ce
chiffre 2900 en 1958 milliards surtout
pas me prendre pour un technicien de
budgétaire que je ne suis pas donc quand
on a rien à dire vaut mieux pas le faire
savoir ce qui m'inquiète davantage c'est
c'est qui détient la dette parce que on
est dans un monde extrêmement mouvant et
on voit bien que l'indépendance la
souveraineté des États sur les outils
sur les outils budgétaires devient
absolument essentiel et la dette
française et pas détenue comme par
exemple au Japon essentiellement par la
France ou l'Europe et c'est ça qui
m'inquiète parce que demain ceux qui
détiennent la part de la dette française
peuvent nous faire chanter du jour au
lendemain pour avec un monde
multilatérale qui est en train de se
radicaliser lui aussi et qui peut avoir
des conséquences là en revanche
dramatique pour nous quand vous regardez
ce chiffre Julie est-ce que ça justifie
la réforme des retraites selon vous
quand vous voyez le
niveau de la dette aujourd'hui alors je
pense que ce sont deux sujets différents
la dette et la réforme des retraites
parce que la réforme des retraites la
question c'est la préservation du régime
par répartition et de l'équilibre entre
les cotisations payées par les actifs et
les pensions versées au retraités donc
là on est sur sur une partie assez
spécifique un peu différente de celle de
la dette publique à proprement parler
même si je pense qu'il y a eu une
tentation voire une tentative de
mélanger un peu les deux juste là de la
part du gouvernement pour précisément
justifier cette réforme je pense qu'on
est sur un sujet qui est qui est
de choses mais quand même effectivement
un peu différent la question c'est qu'en
effet aujourd'hui on a tellement pris
l'habitude de cet argent magique avec le
quoi qu'il en coûte de la période covid
que
la question de cette dette et devenue
une absolument plus une préoccupation en
effet pour les français alors que ça
doit le rester parce que les pays comme
les ménages doivent être si je puis dire
gérer entre guillemets en bon père de
famille mais là encore et je rejoins
Christophe là dessus il faut absolument
faire en sorte que ça ne freine pas les
dépenses dont on a impérativement besoin
notamment pour les publics les services
publics les plus essentiels évidemment
et au premier chef la transition
écologique mais aussi vous l'avez dit
l'école les hôpitaux et j'ajoute bien
sûr toujours la justice vous allez dire
que c'est obsessionnel mais c'est pour
montrer un chiffre Christophe j'aime
beaucoup les chiffres regardez ce
chiffre entre 2017 et 2022 le ratio de
la dette française sur PIB a progressé
de 16% contre 6% seulement en moyenne
dans la zone euro Emmanuel Macron est un
mauvais gestionnaire ou est-ce qu'il y a
un contexte un peu particulier non je
pense qu'il y avait un contexte
particulier et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
on se dit que la dette a beaucoup
augmenté mais pendant le covid on était
bien content que les gens gardent leur
salaire et que les entreprises ne coule
pas donc on a eu raison de faire ça
franchement c'est pas ça cette partie
des politiques gouvernementales que je
remets en cause et aujourd'hui le poids
de la dette n'est pas un gros problème
parce que l'essentiel du stock de la
dette est à 0% ou un demi pour cent
puisqu'on a emprunté évidemment à une
année et pendant des années où le taux
d'intérêt de la dette était extrêmement
faible voir négatif bon mais
tendentiellement avec un taux d'intérêt
qui monte vers les 3%, il est sûr que
dans 20 ans ça coûtera plus cher
qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
ça ne coûte pas très cher mais
tendentiellement si on fait des
projections la dette va coûter plus cher
demain d'où le fait d'avoir des recettes
supplémentaires et en effet tout à
l'heure je pense qu'on ne pourra pas
faire autrement un économiste comme
Patrick Artus qui est pas un gauchiste
un loin de là dit qu'on ne peut pas
faire autrement et on ne pourra pas
faire autrement que de taxer les plus
haut revenus c'est pas sur ce d'en bas
qu'on va pouvoir faire jouer la taxe
heureusement vous avez pas vous avez pas
tant sur le principe mais le problème
c'est que les traits riches ils vont pas
ils ont pas 3000 milliards à
redistribuer c'est pas la hauteur de
l'enjeu si vous voulez il faut que ce
soit il faut que ce soit collectif parce
que je veux dire cette histoire de taxer
indéfiniment les plus riches on voit
bien que ça marche pas en fait par
exemple
toute bête qui était une selle qui a
fait qui a mis en oeuvre Emmanuel Macron
qui est le fait d'avoir ce qu'on appelle
une flat taxe à une taxe minimale ou
maximale simple en fait c'est un plafond
plus qu'un plancher de 30 % sur les
produits financiers ça aboutit au fait
qu'aujourd'hui l'argent du capital
c'est-à-dire quand vous achetez des
actions il y a des gens qui ont des
actions parce que ils ont des assurances
retraite et oui mais le travail est
imposé à 5 ans quasiment donc
aujourd'hui le travail ben bien sûr
parce que vous avez des impôts directs
plus toutes les charges autour
aujourd'hui on taxe beaucoup plus le
capital le travail pardon que le capital
donc évidemment là il y a un moyen de
toucher des gens qui ne sont pas
simplement les plus riches c'est tous
ceux qui ont des actions qui peuvent
être aussi des assurances vie mais cette
idée d'en finir avec la taxe fleuve la
taxe flatteur limité à 30%, ce serait un
moyen de ramener pas mal d'argent entre
on va jouer on va jouer un peu si vous
êtes d'accord on va passer à la rubrique
fake news ou pas je vous donne une
information ou quelque chose qui
ressemble à une information vous me
dites si c'est vrai ou si c'est faux
Emmanuel vous êtes prêts je suis prêt
toujours prêt cette main tendue de
Vladimir Poutine aux manifestants
français contre la réforme la retraite
au cours d'une intervention télévisée le
chef du Kremlin c'est dit très inquiet
de la situation démocratique en France
suite à l'utilisation de l'article 49-3
par le gouvernement il récla même une
enquête internationale et envisage de se
tourner vers la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme c'est une fake news ou
pas c'est vrai moi je pense que c'est
vrai oui moi aussi c'est vrai la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme je suis
pas sûr qu'il l'a laissé la première
partie
c'est toujours c'est toujours présent de
recevoir des leçons par un si grand
démocratique
c'est une fake news du gorafi en
revanche vous aviez raison en revanche
sachez que l'Iran a officiellement
condamné le comportement du gouvernement
français à l'égard des manifestants le
ministre iranien des Affaires étrangères
dit condamné fermement la répression des
manifestations pacifistes du peuple
français on rappelle qu'il y a plus de
500 morts depuis le début du mouvement
pro démocratie en Iran au Royaume-Uni la
loi c'est la loi richissinach le Premier
ministre a été rappelé à l'ordre après
avoir laissé son chien courir sans
laisse dans un parc un parc dans lequel
et bien
les chiens doivent impérativement être
tenus en laisse le flagrant délit a été
constaté par un officier de police qui a
rappelé à l'ordre de chef du
gouvernement britannique est-ce que
c'est une vraie information ou pas
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas c'est
sûr que ce serait pas mal d'avoir des
règles un peu strictes pour les
dirigeants
le Premier ministre avait déjà reçu au
mois de janvier une amende pour ne pas
avoir porté de ceinture au volant de sa
voiture retour en France avec cette main
tendue cette fois d'Emmanuel Macron le
chef de l'État souhaite l'apaisement
dans le dossier de la réforme des
retraites plutôt que 64 ans il propose
désormais un genre de compromis l'âge de
départ à la retraite passera à 63 ans et
12 mois est-ce que c'est une vraie
formation ou pas c'est un poisson
d'avril je pense comme on approche du
premier avril c'est un poisson d'avril
je pense aussi non évidemment c'est une
fake news une fake news du gorafi elle
est plus sérieuse un ex président
américain renvoyait devant la justice et
du jamais vu évidemment Donald Trump a
donc fait il va devenir le premier
ancien chef d'État à être inculpé en
cause une affaire ce qui remonte à 2016
juste avant son arrivée à la Maison
Blanche écoutez cette interview c'était
sur Fox News en début de semaine et
depuis
les gens qui ne m'aiment pas disent que
ce n'est pas une bonne manière de faire
les choses pour notre pays je ne sais
pas si ça aide vraiment mais à mon avis
c'est encore une manière de truquer les
élections ça s'appelle de l'interférence
électorale ils ne peuvent pas gagner
dans les urnes car je fais largement la
course en tête dans les sondages et je
suis très loin devant Joe Biden comme
ils ne peuvent pas gagner normalement
ils font ce genre de choses
fait du trempe on va rappeler un les
détails les contours de cette affaire
l'affaire stormy Daniels Donald Trump
est mis en cause pour avoir acheté le
silence d'une vedette du porno avec des
fonds de sa campagne électorale ce qui
est illégal aux États-Unis le but de la
manœuvre que l'actrice thèse la relation
extra conjugale qu'elle a eu avec Trump
10 ans plutôt un grand jury a donc
tranché pour la première fois un ancien
président américain va être devoir
comparer devant la justice
c'est incroyable Emmanuel non c'est la
suite logique de tout un système qui est
lancé
à la poursuite de Trump et je suis pas
trumpiste je le dis je le dis
immédiatement
mais c'est pas tellement la question la
question c'est comment est-ce qu'il va
se servir de cela pour sa campagne pour
les élections
américains devant un tribunal ça vous
étonne pas normal il y a eu des
présidents qui étaient en charge qui ont
dû qui ont eu à subir des procédures
d'impichment qui est entre guillemets un
petit peu la même chose que ce qui
arrive à Trump aujourd'hui en n'étant
plus en charge donc quand on est en
charge la procédure s'appelle limping
chemin et il y a déjà eu deux présidents
trois présidents qui ont eu qui ont eu
affaire à ING pitchment et quand on est
pris en charge c'est le grand jury c'est
tout à fait c'est tout à fait classique
madame la batonnière de Paris c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour la démocratie
américaine d'une certaine manière oui
alors ce qui est en revanche la mauvaise
nouvelle c'est les tentatives de
pression qui exercent Donald Trump
Donald Trump notamment sur le procureur
de New York dans cette affaire
c'est-à-dire que là on même si on a un
système judiciaire et juridique très
différent aux États-Unis d'ici
les points communs c'est quand même une
forme de populisme de radicalisation des
positions qu'on retrouve évidemment au
combien accentuer chez Donald Trump et
c'est vrai que c'est pressions là sont
pour le coup extraordinairement choquant
et une menace sur l'état de droit sur la
séparation des pouvoirs
on voit que la séparation fonctionne
parfaitement heureusement non mais
heureusement mais ce qui est terrible
c'est qu'il puisse Emmanuel le disait
s'en servir pour
électriser galvaniser sa base électorale
voilà des fins électorales ça c'est là
où il y a un mélange des gens entre si
je puis dire le judiciaire et le je vais
vous montrer la politique la réaction de
Donald Trump suite à l'annonce de cette
mise en examen c'est une persécution
politique une ingérence dans l'élection
et une chasse aux sorcières notre
mouvement et notre partie vont d'abord
vaincre Alvin brag le procureur puis Joe
Biden et nous allons chasser tous ces
démocrates véreux du pouvoir bon ça veut
dire que la justice va être mise à rude
épreuve là Valérie ça veut dire déjà que
pour Donald Trump la meilleure défense
c'est l'attaque il a toujours fait ça
c'est à dire que il nous avait annoncé 8
jours avant que il allait être arrêté
mardi de la semaine dernière ce qui
n'est pas intervenu et il a une façon de
médiatiser et de politiser absolument
tout ce qui lui arrive pour essayer de
rallier l'opinion à son profit au
passage 130 000 dollars je sais pas
pourquoi il les a pas payé lui-même
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'argent ça
aurait été plus simple elles sont
conseillés
ça aurait évité toute cette histoire
mais la question aujourd'hui c'est ce
que le système Trump il continue à
marcher moi j'ai quand même des sérieux
doutes c'est à dire que il y a un
mélange d'invective d'insultes de
mensonges de pression comme vous dites
sur la justice américaine etc c'est vrai
que les Américains sont pas comme les
Français mais on voit bien que en France
l'ultra
verbe ne profite pas je veux dire la
nuit pêche à attaquer énormément la
réforme des retraites c'est le
rassemblement national qui en tire
profit c'est se crier aussi fort et tout
dénoncer tout le temps en proposant rien
pour moi je pense que c'est pas bon pour
le parti républicain Samuel partir
républicain exprès dans quelques
instants mais juste avant sur cette
année qui est énorme est-ce que ça vous
étonne Emmanuel me dit que c'est pas
étonnant Christophe est-ce que ça vous
étonne de voir un président américain
donc ça devrait être mardi prochain
en France de nombreux présidents devant
les tribunaux donc en soi il y a pas de
l'exercice exactement il n'est plus
président
aucun problème ce qui m'inquiète plus
c'est que malheureusement vous pourriez
avoir tort moi je préférerais en effet
que Trump soit battu par des prochaines
élections mais ça n'est pas certain
qu'ils pouvaient penser qu'il aurait été
élu alors que déjà il investivait tout
le monde en 2016 qui pouvait penser que
j'aille à bolsonaro ou madame Meloni en
Italie soit élu et se retrouve président
de soit de la République soit du conseil
dans le cas italien et c'est inquiétant
y compris pour nous parce que là on voit
pour revenir à ce qu'on discutait tout à
l'heure sur Emmanuel Macron et la
réforme des retraites à se mettre contre
le pays on peut arriver à des
catastrophes électorales comme vous le
dites ça peut être Marine Le Pen qui est
engrange d'une certaine façon les
résultats politiques de cette affaire et
donc là c'est des signaux d'alerte qui
montrent que nos démocraties sont
fragiles et qu'il faut vraiment faire
attention à écouter le peuple d'une
certaine façon ce qui est
malheureusement pas toujours le cas on
va parler de cette campagne parce
qu'avant l'annonce de sa mise en examen
Donald Trump était reparti précisément
au combat il avait lancé sa campagne
présidentielle pour 2024 le weekend
dernier il était très en forme écoutez
YouTube
prenez les cinq pires présidents
américains réunis ils n'ont pas fait
plus de mal que ce café Joe Biden à
notre nation en seulement deux petites
années et demi
s'en prend à moi de plus en plus
durement car je me suis engagé
rapidement à mettre fin à la guerre en
Ukraine quand je dis mettre fin je vais
obtenir un accord très vite je connais
les deux protagonistes et on peut en
avoir un très vite mais on ne le peut
qu'à travers la présidente on contrôle
l'argent qui entre et qui sort on peut
obtenir ça j'aurai un accord dans les 24
heures
Donald Trump toujours la même stratégie
toujours
après ce qui évolue un petit peu c'est
n'oubliez pas qu'on est là on entre dans
le cadre des primaires il faut
rassembler son camp et pas rassembler un
maximum d'Américains la question c'est
quelle sera le moteur chez les
républicains si le moteur c'est la
malbouffe intellectuelle moi j'appelle
ça comme ça alors à ce moment-là les
républicains se tourneront vers Trump
parce que il flatte ce côté grâce où y
est et pas très intelligent de du
entrepreneurs de Floride Steve est-ce
qu'on peut dire juste que une semaine
avant l'éditeur les sondages disaient
que les républicains même la veille des
mineurs allaient gagner à les gagner
avec une ampleur encore inédite Valérie
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ce sondage
vous inspire est-ce que voilà c'est sur
la ces deux stratégies évoquées par
Emmanuel est-ce qu'il faut cliver est-ce
qu'il faut être dans la radicalité pour
séduire ses républicains aujourd'hui moi
ce que ça m'inspire c'est que un je suis
d'accord sur les mites termes
c'est-à-dire que la personnalité de
Donald Trump totalement excessive et
outrancière à empêcher le camp
républicain de gagner des mites termes
ce qu'ils auraient dû gagner à tous les
coups et donc il lui en veulent de ça ça
c'est sûr donc je suis aussi convaincu
que il cherche une alternative à Donald
Trump après la grande question
aujourd'hui c'est ce que des Santis
c'est capable d'être l'alternative à
Donald Trump parce que de ce que j'ai
compris de la stratégie du gouverneur de
Floride il essaie de lui emboîter le pas
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu une
pâle copie en fait et que il n'a pas
réussi jusqu'à présent
une personnalité et une société propre
différente et qui se situe en dehors et
ailleurs et du coup on a l'impression
que c'est un sous Trump avec pas
beaucoup de qualité supplémentaires et
pas mal des défauts de Donald Trump
aussi le populisme notamment et le grand
danger c'est celui-là parce que c'est
vrai que sur le papier les républicains
n'ont aucun intérêt à prendre Donald
Trump ils savent qu'ils vont pour moi je
pense à la défaite alors qu'ils ne
pourront pas gagner un autre sondage va
vous démentir décidément
ce sondage qui donne Trump devant Joe
Biden Trump qui l'emporterait avec 46%
des voix pour la présidentielle de
l'année prochaine comment encore une
fois comment on explique ça nous quand
on regarde Donald Trump on rigole un peu
on prend un peu à la dérision comment
vous expliquer ça Christophe comment
pourquoi Donald Trump est aussi
populaire aujourd'hui auprès des
regardez jaillir bolsonaro c'était un
clown au Parlement brésilien c'était
quelqu'un qui était homophobe etc non je
parle de la première élection il a été
élu il a été élu alors évidemment une
fois au pouvoir comme Trump bolsonaro
s'est montré incapable de faire quoi que
ce soit la gestion du covid a été
terrible au Brésil comme elle a été
mauvaise aussi aux États-Unis sous Trump
et donc il a perdu la deuxième fois elle
s'est tant mieux mais tous ces gens là
peuvent revenir d'une certaine façon
comment pouvait-on penser que Mélanie
qui est la chef et la dirigeante d'un
parti qui se proclame néo fasciste qui
soutient
s'est retrouvé aujourd'hui chef du
gouvernement italien donc il y a des
vrais problèmes dans nos démocraties bon
et donc il faut être capable de prendre
les choses de façon différente c'est pas
évident les choses ne font pas de soi
mais je pense que malheureusement je le
crains il y a quand même de forts
risques ou de réels possibilités que
Trump soit réélu l'année prochaine d'une
maladie de notre de notre de nos
démocratie en général je le crains je
pense qu'effectivement on est dans une
conflictualisation
systématique dans ce populisme cette
radicalité cette violence c'est tout
trans on la voit aussi beaucoup chez
nous et elle me fait très peur je pense
que on est nous-mêmes on risque
là-dessus puisque
je reviens à ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure et encore une fois si on défend
entre guillemets manuel Macron c'est pas
pour défendre Emmanuel Macron mais c'est
parce que de chaque côté nous n'avons
que de l'outrans aussi et ça c'est je
pense qu'en effet c'est un c'est un
danger qui nous guette ici aussi
tout alternatifs
du problème c'est celui-là on est
parfaitement
les extrêmes aux États-Unis
ils sont ils sont pas fiables de
première chose deuxième chose c'est que
si on enjambe l'élection primaire et a
supposer deuxième supposition que Trump
gagne cette élection primaire alors la
principale responsabilité reviendra aux
démocrates dans le choix de leurs
candidat pour faire barrage à Trump car
si les démocrates trouvent un candidat
qui soit assez crédible pour porter un
projet face à Trump Trump n'a aucune
chance maintenant si on envoie Biden qui
qui de temps en temps hésite pour
retrouver le prénom de sa femme quand il
est occupé on risque d'avoir des
problèmes
êtes-vous pour ou contre les
trottinettes électriques en
libre-service voilà la question à
laquelle doit répondre les Parisiens la
mairie organise en effet ce dimanche un
grand référendum et tout le monde à son
petit avis écoutez c'est un jeune
adolescent qui conduisait une
trottinette qui me rendrait dedans il y
a 3 ans ou quatre ans donc depuis j'ai
un problème au genou j'ai très peur on
les voit arriver souvent il y a deux
personnes dessus elles nous font dedans
et je pense que là on a plus du tout
c'est devenu l'anarchie en fait
l'atmosphère c'est c'est vraiment bien
et il vaut mieux supprimer les voitures
qui ne trottinette moi je pense qu'on ne
revient pas en arrière la trottinette
aujourd'hui ça représente un nouveau
progrès en termes de mobilité
l'interdire n'a pas de sens est-ce une
bonne idée d'organiser un référendum sur
une telle question deux invités sur ce
plateau ne sont pas du tout du tout du
tout du tout d'accord d'un côté Emmanuel
de l'autre Julie pour vous Emmanuel bah
non c'est pas c'est vraiment pas une
bonne idée c'est scandaleux c'est
scandaleux de dépenser de l'argent
public pour des choses aussi futile
encore une fois qu'elle fasse un
référendum sur
faut-il
réquisitionner ou prendre des sociétés
privées pour enlever les poubelles quand
on en arrive à là où on est arrivé c'est
à dire des problèmes de santé publique
et des problèmes de sécurité sanitaires
ça oui faut faire un référendum quand on
était élu en disant je n'augmenterai pas
les impôts et qu'on s'apprête à les
augmenter de 50 % ça oui on fait un
référendum mais faire un référendum
dépenser de l'argent public quand on
sait que cette ville est endettée
jusqu'au cou pour savoir s'il faut
maintenir les les trottinettes je trouve
ça parfaitement scandaleux elle elle est
le Christophe Colomb de la politique
elle part sans savoir où elle va elle
arrive sans savoir où elle est avec
l'argent des autres et peut-être qu'elle
va découvrir quelque chose peut-être
qu'elle va découvrir la démocratie
directe je lui dis vous avez 45 secondes
oui moi je trouve que c'est assez
vivifiant en réalité c'est à dire que
c'est ça revient à ce qu'on disait aussi
tout à l'heure sur la coexistence entre
une démocratie représentative et une
démocratie plus participative c'est vrai
que les Français ont ce goût quand même
de la politique et ça il faut qu'on s'en
réjouisse parce qu'on les voit
s'exprimer beaucoup et très en demande
de d'expression et je pense que donner
la parole aux Parisiens sur cette
question qui les concerne assez
directement même si les modalités
peuvent éventuellement être critiquables
et d'ailleurs elles sont critiquées et
qu'on risque de se heurter à une assez
faible participation moi je pense que
toute initiative qui va tendre à
rapprocher et à restaurer en quelque
sorte la confiance entre les citoyens et
les institutions va plutôt dans le bon
sens on essaye à notre échelle au
barreau de Paris de le faire aussi et de
faire coexister ces deux types de
démocratie merci beaucoup Julie
effectivement Valérie c'est une bonne
chose peut-être on se plaint toujours de
que le voilà nos dirigeants ne nous
écoutent pas ne nous écoutent plus assez
la voilà on nous demande notre avis j'ai
envie de dire Anne Hidalgo puisque son
nom n'a pas été prononcé encore qui est
à l'origine du référendum à lancé ce
référendum parce qu'elle voulait
interdire les trottinettes et qu'elle
n'a pas assumer
d'être la mère qui allait interdire les
trottinettes donc elle espère que le
référendum va lui donner raison et
qu'elle va pouvoir s'appuyer sur le
peuple parisien le grand peuple parisien
qui ne va pas beaucoup aller voter parce
que je ne sais pas qui c'est qu'il y a
un référendum sur 21 bureau de vote
ouvert dans tout Paris juste titre c'est
important
moi je vais voter oui je vais aller
voter je vais voter oui aux trottinette
au maintien des trottinettes pourquoi
parce que certes il faut les réglementer
il faut que ce soit moins dangereux il
faut pas qu'on ait le droit d'être là
dessus il faut pas que on puisse les
balancer n'importe où etc mais c'est pas
parce que c'est extrêmement mal géré à
Paris que ce n'est pas bien géré dans
plein d'autres villes de France où ça se
passe très bien et que avec un certain
nombre de règles faciles à mettre en
place les choses doivent se passer bien
ça fait partie de la réalité ça fait
partie de la mob ilité urbaine dont on a
besoin mais il faut le faire juste
correctement si un jour un Hidalgo est
capable de faire quelque chose
correctement c'est ce que fait Clément
baume d'ailleurs qui pardon qui
effectivement Clément bon a annoncé un
plan justement pour réguler justement on
va écouter Clément baume
critique cette initiative de la Mairie
de Paris écouter Clément bonne également
ça dépend je regrette justement qu'à
Paris où il y a un rôle un peu
d'exemplarité de vitrines on est
simplifié caricaturé ce débat pour
contre alors qu'on peut faire pour avec
des règles et c'est d'ailleurs ce que je
choisisse des villes y compris des
villes de gauche y compris des villes
écologistes je regrette qu'on caricature
qu'on simplifie c'est un peu une mesure
de gauche sur référendum sans remettre
au peuple pour dessiner parce que c'est
vrai que Anne Hidalgo fait ça parce que
depuis la présidentielle elle essaie de
rebondir avec c'est difficile ça on le
voit bien mais un moi je suis assez
d'accord avec Julie je pense que c'est
bien de donner la parole aux gens quand
c'est possible et pourquoi pas sur ce
sujet comme sur des tas d'autres je
pense que cet articulation entre
démocratie représentative et démocratie
directe ou démocratie participative
c'est une bonne chose et puis
deuxièmement les mobilités douces c'est
important on va pas réussir à diminuer
les particules fines et la pollution
dans des villes comme Paris si on ne
développe pas le vélo si on développe
pas les trottinettes alors est-ce que il
faut que ce soit réglementer oui donc
pour une fois on va se retrouver
d'accord avec le gouvernement faire une
réglementation là-dessus imposée que ce
soit en effet dans les parcours de
cycliste que les trottinettes soient et
pas les trottoirs ce genre la même chose
ça va de soi il faut le faire mais moi
je veux rien contre les trucs
je dis simplement que il y a elle
devrait faire des référendum sur des
choses plus extrêmement
grande comme un test mais si vous voulez
que ça réussisse et que ce soit un test
qui qui fasse des petits il faut le
faire sur un sujet important ça c'est
pas un sujet important quand elle a
quand elle a supprimé non quand elle a
supprimé les Bolloré car les elle a pas
fait de référendum jusqu'à preuve du
contraire on a tellement voulu que
maintenant elle fait un référendum
pas sa propre position
elle veut elle veut faire valider vous
avez entièrement raison elle veut faire
valider par les Parisiens une position
qu'elle a déjà prise enfin je veux dire
elle se moque elle a dit qu'elle s'en
remettra à l'avis des Parisiens
d'accord
c'est quand on est deux sur une
trottinette c'est pas compliqué de dire
on n'a pas le droit d'être deux sur une
trottinette alors on dit on dit
régulièrement que dans un référendum on
ne vote pas pour la question est-ce que
c'est ça va être un référendum pour
contre Anne Hidalgo d'une certaine
manière
parce que
ils savent pas qu'elle essaie de faire
avaliser sa position contre par les gens
donc les gens ils sont ils sont perdus
ils comprennent pas bien la question
Hidalgo a eu lieu lors de la
présidentielle elle a fait moins de voix
au niveau national qu'elle en a fait
deux ans avant sur sa dans sa propre
ville 27 pour voilà donc Julie n'est pas
d'accord avec cette idée de référendum
pour ou contre un Hidalgo voilà c'est
vrai que quand on fait un référendum au
niveau national c'est souvent sur la
personne c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'Emmanuel Macron est peut-être un peu
hésite avant d'y aller est-ce que là
c'est ça va être un peu le cas ce
référendum au niveau alors c'est pas
exactement référendum c'est légalement
je crois que c'est un peu différent sans
être une grande stratège je pense qu'il
y a effectivement Paris qui est que ne
vont vraisemblablement se déplacer que
ceux qui sont contre et donc en effet
même s'il y a peu de participation et
encore une fois sans faire de Paris
peut-être que ce sera le pour qu'il
l'emportera mais c'est vrai que
j'imagine assez volontiers que ce sont
plutôt ceux qui seront contre qui vont
se déplacer pour voter et donc valider
ce qu'elle pense elle et c'est voilà
c'est pas c'est juste ce point sur
lequel je fais pas tout à fait d'accord
avec Valérie c'est que je pense pas
qu'elle avance Pasquier elle a elle elle
dit ce qu'elle pense elle elle est
personnellement contre je pense qu'elle
le dit avec une certaine clarté et que
d'une certaine façon elle va essayer de
faire valider entériner ce qu'elle pense
elle par le biais de se référendum pour
les circulations douces à condition que
on utilise que les que les modes de
transport que elle autorise
non mais là c'est en l'occurrence c'est
les trottinettes en libre-service on
peut toujours s'acheter une trottinette
mais vous en avez une heure
je suis pas contre les trottinettes mais
j'ai ma propre trottinette mais je sais
pas je pense que c'est pas le sujet bon
Emmanuel
comme chaque semaine en termites cette
émission par un top flow je vous pose
une question très simple qui a marqué
l'actualité de la semaine en bien ou en
mal Emmanuel c'est à vous vous commencez
votre top et votre flop mon top c'est
Edouard Philippe j'ai trouvé que son
congrès la semaine dernière de horizon
était de très très bonne qualité avec
une hauteur de vue qui fait plaisir à
avoir et à entendre dans une vie
politique qui est morcelée par les
petites phrases et mon flop c'est la
faillite du Crédit Suisse racheté par
HSBC qui me fait craindre le pire parce
que c'est comme ça que ça a commencé en
2008 aux États-Unis cette fois-ci cette
fois-ci c'est en Europe et on a vu
d'ailleurs immédiatement les
conséquences que ça a sur les banques
françaises et on me dit moi que les
banques allemandes sont également
sur la sellette avec des actifs pourris
à l'intérieur
votre top et votre flop alors mon top va
vous surprendre mais c'est effectivement
la sortie hier d'Emmanuel Macron dans
les Alpes pas pour ce qu'il a dit sur un
parti politique mais pour sa politique
de l'eau je pense que l'eau est un sujet
extrêmement important qu'il était
urgent qu'on s'y attaque et que
augmenter le recyclage des eaux et que
10% des eaux soient recyclées dans ce
pays c'est une urgence c'est seulement
1% aujourd'hui ça peut pas continuer
comme ça la sobriété de l'eau je suis
pour et le fait que en taxe l'eau de
confort aussi donc même si politiquement
la séquence est difficile pour lui le
fond de son sujet était un sujet
important il a été inaudible et c'est
dommage et votre flop et mon flop a bah
c'est mon regret que Charles III soit
allé en Allemagne avant d'aller en
France je trouve que ça en dit
extrêmement long symboliquement et d'un
point de vue international sur la
situation de la France en ce moment et
je trouve ça
extrêmement découragé
et on a raté la scène Christophe watov
votre flop mon top ça va être le GIEC
qui a quelques jours a rendu son rapport
une fois de plus alors c'est un TOP
malheureux puisque d'une certaine façon
de l'alerte que vous portez le GIEC
montre qu'il faut vraiment prendre des
mesures fortes mais heureusement qu'ils
sont là pour nous rappeler régulièrement
que si on ne s'y met pas maintenant
l'avenir de l'humanité sera difficile et
votre flop mon flop c'est les grandes
banques françaises la palme qui ont été
perquisitionnés par 160 inquiétaires
cette semaine pour un nouveau scandale
qui a été révélé par la presse en quoi
la presse libre peut être vraiment utile
qui sont les com comme c'est le nom
technique de cette opération
qui sont d'une opération bancaire dans
lequel les grandes banques européennes
pas que françaises ont une tactique ou
une pratique qui consiste à laisser les
opérateurs étrangers qui ont des actions
en France les prêter entre guillemets à
ses banques pour une journée pour
permettre tout simplement qu'ils ne
payent pas d'impôts la perte fiscale
pour la France c'est évalué entre 400
millions et 1 ça ne résoudra pas tout à
fait la dette mais ça peut aller dans le
bon sens donc c'est un flop pour les
banques françaises votre top et votre
flop alors mon top c'est la mobilisation
du peuple israélien qui a réussi à faire
mettre en pause la réforme de la justice
[Applaudissements]
donc engagé par Benyamin netanyo pour le
premier engagé par un Netanyahou
vraisemblablement à certains égards on
peut pas l'exclure à des fins
personnelles puisque et là encore on se
retrouve avec un sujet de séparation des
pouvoirs la volonté était clairement
affichée d'affaiblir les pouvoirs de la
Cour suprême israélienne en permettant
que le Parlement annule des décisions
qui ne lui conviendraient pas avec
également une réforme sur la désignation
effectivement des magistrats et mon flop
c'est le les difficultés qu'à rencontrer
le maire
de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins qui a vu sa
permanence brûlée etc et c'est vrai que
on revient toujours là aussi à la
violence contre les élus et elle est
nécessité de les respecter en général la
violence en général
merci à tous les cas d'avoir participé
salut à vous derrière votre écran on me
dit dans l'oreillette que vous êtes de
plus en plus nombreux à nous suivre
continuer vous pouvez aussi nous
retrouver en replay et en podcast on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine même jour
mm heure et même endroit bye bye